child labor is a global problem from
Afghanistan to India to honduras in the
mid-2000s reports emerged that whose
Becca Stan was shuttering schools and
forcing kids as young as 11 into the
cotton fields it led the european
parliament in 2011 to freeze a draft
textiles deal with the former soviet
state since then more than 250 companies
have pledged not to use Beck cotton
picked by child slaves but the situation
has changed and maria arena parliaments
lead negotiator on the textiles deal
says the country deserves a chance
uzbekistan otoko Assad regime keygen
dictator treasure Oh poo head commandeer
money Perico have excessive red mmmm toy
info ojj the dialog info sooke near
Lizzie firkins Bautista a fit the
International Labour Organization says
child labour has been virtually
eradicated but there are still
widespread concerns about the use of
forced adult labor we have plenty of
reports by independent civil society
organizations that say that forced
labour is still there in an amount which
simply does not make the glass really
half full any PS have agreed to open EU
markets to use back textiles but they
say they will pull the plug if the
situation worsens
[Music]